that we will do what the consumer thing
happens but when the going gets tough
the cash is of a business is the oxygen
you could be the most ideological epic
awesome person and by the way you know
this this is the biggest Insight the
humans are saying this
but what happens when the humans
themselves act differently when the
going gets tough Vayner Nation how are
you another exciting episode of the
garyvee audio experience with uh well
the man that um some of you already know
and many will discover uh and I think
this conversation is going to go quite
well we just laughed we had one second
before we went on I said Ellen anything
you want to talk about he goes whatever
you want to talk about I'm like good
this is going to be a great I'm gonna be
able to do a lot Elmer uh why don't you
uh I always like to let the guests take
the first minute or two to create the
context with the audience I always uh
want to make sure that they can position
uh the context the way they want so why
don't you fire away and tell the Vayner
Nation a little bit about who you are
and yourself and your career and then
we'll go into it well I'm a lifelong
journalist and also to some degree a
lifelong entrepreneur I started my first
newspaper when I was nine years old uh I
stayed in you know edited my co my high
school newspaper College Newspaper
worked many years at the Wall Street
Journal ran the Washington Bureau uh uh
did a few years uh uh uh doing his show
at CNBC uh then came to Fortune and I'm
now the CEO of Fortune so it's a it's a
fairly consistent storyline it it it's
not too uh it's not too confusing I I I
suspect the reason I'm here Gary you'd
have to tell me that but I suspect the
reason I'm here is because of a book
I've written recently called tomorrow's
capitalist that was my attempt to try
and get my head around what was going on
why I was hearing more and more Business
Leaders talk more directly and
intentionally about their impact on
society something very different was is
going on in the conversations I was
having with CEOs and the book was my
attempt to understand it and explain it
so let's let's just go there you know
obviously when you think about the Wall
Street Journal when did you start at the
journal let's start this actually I I
started the journal in
1983. perfect that's even that's exactly
what I was hoping for so everybody can
understand where I'm going with this
in 1983 at the Wall Street Journal how
many CEOs running those Fortune 500
companies
even nuanced the concept of something
that their Coca-Cola or IBM or Chevy had
impact on the world
yeah
relatively few I mean there was sort of
some cases out there that you could
point to I think of you know the history
of a company a company like Cummins
engine that was such so inherently a
part of its Community but it was uh uh
look we were in the thralls of Milton
Friedman the great Economist who said
the social responsibility of businesses
to make a profit uh and I think that was
in the 1980s very much the reigning
frame do you think that there's a danger
that if it goes
so the opposite way of that POV that
these things don't become sustainable
and I'll tell you where I'm going with
that question yeah yeah my great
Obsession right now in America and I
think about it globally but obviously
America is who it is in the scheme of
capitalism and societal ambition that as
America goes more red more blue you know
we're pulling
that the answer is purple
it's the blend of the two and that you
know I for example have incredible
ambition and hopes and I love being an
entrepreneur but I genuinely do like
Civility and kindness and I I think it's
very easy to build a business that is
profitable and can be nice and a
positive impact but I also believe
that there's not a business on Earth
nor is there a human on earth that
doesn't have shortcomings in some social
framework no question but if you ask
businesses to be great at everything
that we could go too far and and kind of
lose our Collective way but uh it's a
fair concern and and and we should talk
about it and I appreciate the fact you
put it in a political context but let me
just take it out of the political
context first let me give you another
context for what I think is going on you
know there was a uh some research done a
few years ago about
how how are businesses creating how do
businesses create value and they looked
at the Fortune 500
in uh the 1970s and they looked at the
balance sheets and said where's the
value value coming from at these
corporations and what you saw in the
1970s was more than 80 percent of the
value came from physical stuff it was a
plant it was equipment it was oil in the
ground it was inventory on the shelves
it was physical things that you needed
Financial Capital to to buy and build
yes if you do the exact same exercise
today
what you'll find is more than 85 percent
of the value of Fortune 500 companies is
coming from intangibles it's coming from
intellectual property it's becoming from
the brand value with the consumer all of
all of which are things that aren't tied
to physical so much to physical stuff or
financial Capital they're tied to people
they're tied to human beings they're
tied to your employees to walk in and
out the door and your customers who have
a sense of brand loyalty for you I mean
this is this is your business Gary you
understand this so I think what's really
going on here is not a politicization of
business it's a human
humanization if that's a word yeah a
business that that you know we I have a
colleague Jeff Colvin who wrote a great
book called humans are underrated one of
the things he said in the book is we
spent the 20th century trying to make
people into better machines they were
cogs in the great in the great Factory
you know and they were supposed to do
their role to make the machine work
better yep in the 21st century the
machines are taking care of themselves
thank you very much we need people to be
better people and so all of these things
that I'm writing about and talking about
the increased focus on contribution to
society is much more about that than it
is about politics per se
talk to me about things that are in the
water
that challenged us humans to be better
for instance something I'm obsessed with
I'm so pumped I get to ask you this yeah
the notion that nice guys finish last
when no in the context of the combo you
and I are having right now I'm
fascinated by that
because I have a lot of empathy for the
women and men in business that I
interact with all the time that don't
even realize that that's the thing that
they believe that's leading to their
concern of overleading with their
emotional intelligence or their heart
and thoughts on that if I throw that out
oh my god well look I I think in some
ways that's the uh one of the biggest
changes you just used look we've already
established that I've been doing this
stuff for four decades right so I've
seen quite a lot of this yes you just
used a word empathy
that I can tell you for three and a half
Decades of covering business I never
heard a business leader use just did not
happen and I just got off a a phone call
with a dozen CEOs who were talking about
Wellness in the workplace and I heard
the word 15 times in the course of one
hour I I don't think that's just a
semantic change I think that's a
dramatic change in the way that Business
Leaders think about their uh about their
jobs uh yeah do you believe the
operators that believe in Merit
competition
um tenacity all things I believe in by
the way yeah of course uh get over
concerned when they hear empathy and
these things that that that they
struggle with balancing the two because
they don't realize it's an and versus an
or is that your take I gotta tell you
and maybe it's the maybe it's the CEOs I
hang out with you know I've spent a lot
of time on this topic over the last five
years and so maybe the the people I'm
hearing from are self-selected group but
I don't hear that anymore you know I
think that would probably have been true
if you were talking to Jack Welch and
remember only 20 years ago that was only
20 years ago but man I don't hear you
know one of the one of the uh most
amazing corporate statements that
happened during the pandemic came from
the CEO of Marriott
um Arne Sorensen who when it when it
became clear that his business was going
to drop by 95 or more I mean about that
it's just people weren't in in the
hotels and and so the the company didn't
have the financial wherewithal to keep
everybody employed and he made a Twitter
message you can search this on Twitter
uh to send to his employees uh to
explain why he was furloughing so many
of them uh uh it just so happened that
at the same time he was making that
message he personally was suffering from
very severe cancer which subsequently
killed him and he you know was showing
the effects of the cancer treatment uh
but my God it's a two-minute video I was
in tears by the time the thing was over
I mean this is a CEO telling his
Workforce that their jobs have
disappeared
um but the but the way he did it the the
you know the way he explained it to him
it was sort of a masterpiece of
transparency and vulnerability and
empathy and all the things that the Jack
Welch's of the world 20 years ago would
never dreamed of doing so it's you know
a dramatic illustration of the of how
Tides have changed
what do you think are the masses from
your perspective spending so much time
what do you think are the massive
benefits
and what do you think are the changes
that will become new challenges because
you know when you have these kind of
seismic gifts you know this is all this
is all wonderful I mean you're talking
to somebody who started a wine brand
called empathy you know like I've been
on this train for a long time because
I'm very much my mother's son and she
was built on incredible emotional
intelligence and compassion and I very
proud of how I've operated
on the flip side recessions
that are aggressive and sustained
America losing its pedestal of being the
economic dominant player you know do you
believe that this is
potentially a trend in the maturity of a
superpower that when challenged
um may have a tough time finding its
balance in some of this because
as organizations find their way I can
tell you as one that is built so my
company's code word internally is the
honey Empire
honey over vinegar but we're building an
empire
we have a thousand plus 27 and under
year olds
so Gary I think I I'll finish this in
this I'm a guy in your take the thing I
spend time on is how do I make this the
greatest
from all those emotional Frameworks and
how do I also not create entitlement
that creates the vulnerability of the
task at hand
and what I for me I'm confident because
I don't have a board I'm not a publicly
traded company and I'm in my most joyous
when the people around me are yeah but I
have empathy for people that are going
to have to deal with a public board a
public company competition and so when
the going gets tough
I'm worried that they may deviate from
words like empathy towards like we've
got to compete maybe but here's what's
so interesting about what's happening
right first of all let me say you don't
ask simple questions
that's a compliment right that is a
compliment yeah so
um so in fact if you want to you know
like go refill your Starbucks uh cup it
may take a look I'll try and come I'll
try and I'll try and keep my answer
concise take your time because I think
the depth is interesting and I think you
have a great perspective so I'm excited
so so you asked about the good part of
this and then you asked about the parts
that I think are may not be sustainable
and and and I'm gonna I'm gonna put in a
little bit less of a political context
than you did and sort of just focus on
business per se please the good part is
you know things like climate and things
like diversity equity and inclusion I
think five years ago most Business
Leaders thought well those are important
but they're kind of nice to Do's you
know they're like Corporate social
responsibility I should do it because
I'm a good person yeah what's what's
happened in the last two years that's so
fascinating is it has become a business
in imperative
you know start with climate I had this
fascinating conversation with Soren SKU
who is the CEO of uh molar mask that
runs the big shipping uh
ships all over the world and and he has
made this massive investment in hydrogen
power using uh wind power in the North
Sea it is not economic there is no
current economic rationale for making
the investment he made and so I said
why'd you do it why are you spending all
this money on something that is just
there's no way that's going to get close
to the price of fossil fuel and he said
I did it because every day I get a call
from a customer who says I just made
this Net Zero climate commitment that
requires me to get the carbon emissions
out of my supply chain and you're my
supply chain if you don't figure out how
to operate your ships uh without carbon
emissions I can't meet my goal and so
there's this kind of
reinforcing thing going on that has made
it no longer just a good thing but a
business imperative think about GM I
mean Mary Barra the CEO of GM made this
extraordinary commitment in January of
last year she's only going to make
electric cars by 2035. yeah and that's
not just buying the sky commitment I
mean she has to start investing against
that commitment
she had to start the day she made the
commitment
um so did she do it because she thought
it was the right thing to do for the
environment yes but did she also do
because she was afraid Tesla was going
to take her business away from her yes
so so
it's become a business imperative
couldn't agree more and just and just
one other thing before I finish it
because you you talked about diversity
and equity and inclusion same thing we
are in a massive battle for talent that
most CEOs I talk to don't think is going
to go away even with a recession and so
if you're not figuring out how you
create new pipelines for disa you know
for people who've been overlooked to
bring them into the workforce you're
you're probably not going to win the
town of War
Alan are you telling me that
in the last hundred days the CEOs that
you're talking to do not feel that
there's going to be a correction in the
job market if the recession keeps going
in the direction that it's going we we
just did a survey just fresh out of the
field that shows that more than
two-thirds of CEOs think there's going
to be a recession
but then you ask them what is the single
biggest challenge you face and you know
what it is it's not the recession
Talent so yes I I mean will there be a
correction maybe but we've never had a
moment where we are talking about
recession and we're looking at three and
a half percent unemployment at the same
time that never happened before it's
going to be interesting because what's
the dynamic that don't people don't see
is that the internet has created so many
options for people to make six figures a
year
do it with their side hustles that the
fragmentation of the long tail of the
economics is very real the question will
become
things like hey Gary I don't need to get
a job because I'm selling things on
Amazon and making 150k a year but if
Amazon has to raise their fees because
of a recession does that become viable
like where the trickle-down economics
all these influencers you can imagine my
world Gary I mean 200 000 a year in
brand deals I don't need to get a job
well if the marketing budgets go into a
different or you know so it's gonna be
there's so many macro trends that are
happening that may be affected in the
micro with a recession that will be an
interesting game to see play out and
what's happening on the other side of
that equation again again this is the
Dozen CEOs I was just on the line with
this is what they were talking about
what's happening on the other side of
that equation is companies are just
getting better at figure out figuring
out what they have to do to attract
retain engage excite
people to come and work for them you
know that it's just becoming their their
focusing intentionally on how do I make
this a better experience because if I
don't make it a better experience I'm
not going to get the people I need I
have such double feelings right now I am
so excited
that a um Observer of your pedigree and
social commentator to the sector I've
Loved I followed business like it was
Sports my whole life I I'm pinching
myself that this is the conversation
we're having if you told me if you told
1998 Gary who came into his dad's liquor
store with objective number one is to be
more kind to our employees that stopped
ourselves that this would be a 2022
conversation I would pinch myself out of
happiness on the flip side as 2022 Gary
who's watched 2020 to 2022
and has interacts daily with Fortune 500
CEOs and CMOS
the disconnect between the ambition of
the Ivory Tower and the execution in the
trenches is such a grand Gap right now
that I'm curious about the speed in
which these conversations you're having
become actually executable yeah and I I
I thank you for taking me back because I
never answered the your question of what
are the limits of this where where does
look this doesn't mean this is not greed
is dead you know this is like corruption
is over this is not I mean look I spent
uh I spent a couple of years as the
chief content officer for time Inc when
there was still a timing before it went
under yes and I was in the c-suite of
that company when it was under attack
from uh shareholder activists who wanted
it to produce more money each quarter
yeah and what you see when you're in
that position is there are
hundreds of bad things you can do when I
say bad it's bad for your employees it's
bad for the your customers it's bad for
the environment environment maybe uh bad
for the long-term health of the of the
company but there are hundreds of bad
things you can do that will make you
money in that quarter
yes sir and and when you got a
shareholder activist breeding breathing
down your throat you know I see now Mark
benioff has one uh right yeah say we
want more money next quarter
gotta hold them up stop all this all
this fluffy talk so no question there
are a bunch of short-term money-based
pressures that can push companies to do
bad things and companies will continue
to succumb to those pressures but but
what I'm saying is as somebody who has
watched this for four decades there is a
set of
countervailing pressures in place yes
that are causing more and more corporate
leaders to take a much more serious look
at their social impact and at the
long-term impact of their companies and
I don't think that's a silver bullet or
solves all our problems but I think it's
a good thing I do too I I think it's a
great thing because back and again I'm
actually not using politics I just think
it's so easy for people to grasp given
the macro let's use a seesaw you don't
have to use red and blue let's use a
seesaw to your point
if the Seesaw is balanced left to right
and this is not about what you're saying
which excites the [ __ ] out of me
personally is this is not seesaw going
right to left this is the Seesaw is
going flat yeah and the reason the
reason I reject I mean they're they're
you know look I worked many many years
at the Wall Street Journal I know the
folks on the editorial page very well
um uh they've been leading the attack
against woke CEOs and you know saying
that this is all a bunch of misguided
Business Leaders trying to pay play
footsie with Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren or something like that
the reason I think that's so misguided
well let me use an example to make the
case uh two weeks ago I was down in
Bentonville Arkansas with Doug McMillan
uh Doug McMillan is CEO of Walmart has
to be about as you know that has to be
about as red of a CEO and has read of a
company that you can imagine I mean he
grew up in Arkansas his first job was
loading trucks at Walmart the company
serves red America right that's who
their employees are that's who their
customers are but he has said we want
this company to become the first truly
regenerative company sounds like
something mark benioff would say okay
and and he has challenged his suppliers
to get a gigaton of carbon emissions out
of the environment and you know how how
uh how Walmart in fact the buyers and he
has said and he's changed the way you
know Sam Walton great businessman that
he was I'm pretty sure thought of
employees as an input and his job was to
get the price of that input as low as he
could so pay the absolute lowest wages
Doug McMillan has completely changed the
way wages are said
we like to pay better wages I I tell my
friends all the time that take it to the
extremes I'm with you to me this is not
about that to me this is about common
sense to me this is not about politics
this is consumer centricality what
you're referring to is if the humans are
85 percent of the thing and this little
humans feel we're going to do what the
humans feel because that's the customer
yeah I'm fully on board I think what's
going to be most interesting to me
because I'm fully on board and so I
wanted you here and I like this middle
the Seesaw will use instead of the red
blue
um is
that we will do what the consumer thing
happens but when the going gets tough
the cash is of a business is the oxygen
you can be the most ideological epic
awesome person and by the way you know
this this is the biggest Insight the
humans are saying this
but what happens when the humans
themselves act differently when the
going gets tough that's where I'm you
know
I'm I can't I'm a very emotionally
charged human I kind of by default care
about what everybody cares about like
like it's just kind of like my way
um look look I I I I totally thought
when the pandemic hit and it became
clear that the economy was going to go
down into a recession uh and that was
about a year after the Business
Roundtable had issued its kind of
stakeholder governance statement I
totally thought based on past experience
all of the stakeholder capitalism stuff
was going to go away that all these
social concerns well guess what it would
have if we didn't print money
because we haven't felt it yet that
becomes upon the beef right like you
know this like if we don't print that
money
everything's different you have an
entire generation of under 30 this is
important I think you'll like this Allen
I because I'm in love with my employees
and I talk to them all the time and I
have all these 27 29 year old employees
like you know Gary really believe what
you're saying try to be thoughtful of my
money like you know
covid you know I'm so glad I got to go
through covet it was tough I'm like you
got checks in the mail
what do you mean tough this wasn't you
know and then I have all these 35 year
olds who went in 2008 and they're
watching the 35 year olds talk to 25
year olds in my office is my favorite
because the 25 year old thinks covid
was what 2008 was and it surely wasn't
you had people sitting at home getting
paid more to be at home than work that's
all that's a fair point and when the
money goes away you can't spend the
money no question about that that's what
my whole point is I'll tell you where my
energy is coming from if anybody's
confused listening I'm So Into what Alan
is saying that I'm hoping and praying
because I do sense that it might get a
little tough here for a little bit for
real and I'm hoping we don't lose our
way yeah I and I hope you're right
here's what I'm hearing from the best
companies what I hear from the best
companies is you know why I was one
business leader the other day quoted
that uh Formula One race car driver who
said I can't pass 15 cars in the Sun but
I can pass 15 cars when it's raining
when I'm here Business Leaders saying is
recession is when you really have to
prove your stuff if we believe our
differentiator in the future is going to
be commitment to the environment and
commitment to people then we have to
hold on and stick to it and maybe even
double down on it in the tough times in
order to win the future because we don't
do that somebody else will and they'll
get ahead of us so there's a sense that
this has become part of the competitive
Dynamic of business
not only is there a sense you're
actively talking to somebody who for the
last 120 days has told us 50 direct
reports that the next two years are
going to be the biggest growth maybe in
my career because we've committed to
people for a decade and it's going to
matter now there you go and I still love
you for it I salute you for it Gary I
tell people all the time it's not
because
um Mother Teresa or altruistic it's the
purple it's the
flat seesaw it's both now matter it's an
and game it's not or our friends to the
to the left or right or purple blue like
where they get concerned is they live in
a world of ore they think it's all going
to go to this it's not it's about the
middle and Gary if I can just say one
more thing I mean when I when I started
my career the business World defined the
right to now I'm going to politics yeah
business world to find the right wing of
the spectrum but what's happened in our
system politics has gotten broken uh uh
both the left and the right are no
longer about solving problems they're
just about gaining political advantage
in the next election business people
have to solve problems you can't be a
successful business person if you don't
solve problems so by definition you're
purple because the the red the blue are
not solving problems brother that
couldn't be a better way to end this I
believe that there is a real chance for
the business Community to play that
purple role in a meaningful real way
over the next three decades and it's
going to be fun to watch if that's true
or not or how why or not but I really
appreciate discussion I have a feeling a
lot of people got a lot of value from it
I hope you enjoyed it my friend great
fun thank you for having me and by the
way Vayner Nation I I know because all
the authors email me three four weeks
later that this is a obnoxiously big
book buying Community if you if you
enjoyed this Alan's absolutely right I
you know it's funny I don't consume
information through long book form but I
write them and I advocate for them
because ninety percent of you listening
right now do and I think Alan's got
something for you so one more time Alan
so they can all go to Amazon or Barnes
and Noble or local bookstore what's the
name of the book One More Time
tomorrow's capitalist my search for the
soul of business and all the profits go
to Fortune so uh if uh uh you can
support good journalism in the process
my friend I wish you nothing but health
and happiness thank you Gary cheers
great to be with you
[Music]